hi everyone I hope you all are doing
great
finally hamara first exams
so much Solutions
[Music]
Hi
how are you
Clash of Clan nice name hi
which side is easy that you will get to
know after some time please wait wait
wait
[Laughter]
so I guess most of you are thinking that
the paper was easy everyone says
everyone feels that
paper or it was moderate or people was
difficult
what do you think
ah okay happy birthday
okay so moderate it was moderate
okay good
session
please like the session share the link
with your friends Solutions
foreign nice name
hi and Aruna
hanji to Charlie English
hi hi Nadeem
foreign
yes very good ah ma'am please announce
my name is
Solutions
paper
yes sure sure
so guys shall we start are you all ready
sir please come
thank you man thank you so much
[Music]
so I think uh the paper is not so tough
I think every child who has been uh
today's exam must have done well
I hope we see a happy face
on all their faces mom yes
saying I will score 80 out of 80. so
he's so confident about the paper yes
Shivam very good to hear from you uh
hope you really get the score you expect
and today we see the key also wish you
all the best for that foreign
[Music]
now over to you sir
yes sir thank you ma'am thank you so
much
let us continue the session dear
students
let me read out the paragraph for you
and before we read the paragraph you
know that this is a passage
a topic which is uh
being a very familiar one to you
you have learned a lot about it and now
you are going to see something more and
as it is an own passage to you I am sure
the way the questions are asked could be
a easy one for you to answer well
to begin let's continue
organic food is very popular these days
it can also be very expansive
some organic food cost twice as much as
non-organic food
parent of young children and even some
pet owners will pay high prices of
organic organic food if they think it is
healthier
but many others think
organic food is just a waste of money
We are continuing some people think
organic also means locally grown
and originally it was indeed true
but over a period of time organic
farming has become a big business with
many organic foods now being grown by
large agricultural companies that sell
their products far from where they are
grown
processed food made with Organic
ingredients has also become more popular
at first only small companies produced
these products but as demand overtook
Supply big food companies that had been
selling non-organic products for many
years also began selling organic
products
is organic food safer and more
nutritious
this is an important part of the debate
many farmers and consumers believe it is
safer and more nutritious
they think agricultural chemicals can
cause serious illnesses such as cancer
but there isn't much evidence
proving this is true
however recent Studies have also shown
that eating organically grown
produce
reduces your chances of developing heart
diseases
many doctors think it is more important
to stop dangerous bacteria from
contaminating Foods
these bacteria can contaminate both
organic and non-organic fruits and
vegetables and doctors recommend washing
produce carefully before eating it
meat Fish and Chicken can also become
contaminated so washing your hands
before handling these Foods is also very
important
now that is the paragraph dear students
now let's see based on your
understanding of the passage answer the
questions given below
okay hope you are ready let's continue
with the first question dear students
people are willing to pay high prices
for organic food
because
you have to supply this answer
right so why are people willing to pay
high prices for organic food I'm sure as
it is equation which is directly asked
from the passage your answer is also
ready and easy for you let's go with
option A it is not easily available
it helps in weight loss
it is produced by small companies
and option D it does not contain
agricultural chemicals
okay now out of all these options it is
pretty clear that people are willing to
pay high prices for organic food because
it does not contain agricultural
chemicals so
option
D will be the answer
option D is the correct one for this
dear students
okay next
let us go with the second question
select the option that displays what the
writer projects with reference to the
following
okay this is a statement taken from the
passage
right from paragraph four we have this
is organic food safer and more
nutritious
this is an important part of the debate
now dear students this is a statement
taken from paragraph four and we need to
identify the option that displays what
the writer projects now is it option a
denial
option b confirmation option caution and
option D acceptance
if you see these answer options you know
from the way it is questioned is organic
food safer and more nutritious
this is an important part of the debate
you know when we have this kind of
question like this we are very sure to
go with the incorrect options like uh
denial is incorrect because it's nowhere
related to denying something
and
between ah okay let's go with the next
option like if you see option b
confirmation option caution
okay there is no clue in this which says
like it is giving any caution it's not
even alerting
and we are left with option b and d
option b is confirmation and option D is
acceptance
yes we know that organic food is
accepted to be safe and nutritious now
people want to see it confirmed that is
why we can go with option b showing that
it is only and you see this one this is
an important part of the debate so
debate is where you would like to go
with some confirmation some proofs
okay okay dear students so see that for
the second one option b is the correct
answer it is showing the confirmation it
is only to confirm whether uh organic
food is safer or
not
let's continue with the third one
third question
complete the following with a phrase
from paragraph three
dear students in many of the practice
papers we had this
ah you know the way it is a bit
confusing this time usually in the past
in this sqp given by the board and even
in the practice paper
opinion was something that was asked
for the student you know student has to
identify the opinion and reason was
supplied
but at this time it's not like a reason
which is supplied openly supplied and
you need to identify the reason now what
is the opinion big food companies have
started selling organic food products
okay big food companies have started
selling organic food products now what
is the reason why did the big companies
started selling this just if you just
refer to paragraph three
you have a direct clue here
some people think
students have a glance at it some people
think organic also means locally grown
and originally it was indeed true but
over a period of time organic farming
has become a big business
with many organic foods now being grown
by large agricultural companies that
sell their products far from where they
are grown this is the opinion what we
see right so what we see there we see
that ah in the question
big companies have started selling
organic food products that is what we
have here now what is the reason
processed food made with Organic
ingredients has also become more popular
so here we can find out the answer right
from
uh
this line
organic farming has become a big
business or organic farming has become
popular
okay that could be one possible answer
and we also can identify the answer with
this clue processed food made with
Organic ingredients
processed food made with Organic
ingredients so if you have written
something that is related to this
concept like the ingredients that are
used and the way it has become very
popular as it is grown naturally no that
would be the answer
okay that the phrase what you write
should identify should give this meaning
that it is naturally grown and these
products have become very popular and
the processed food made with Organic
ingredients
so given that let's continue with the
the next question
number four
the writer contrasts
organic food to non-organic food State
one point of comparison between the two
so it's very easy question dear students
are you a student studying science and
so on would be would find it very easy
for you to answer this one okay what is
what is this comparison between organic
food and non-organic food we know that
organic food
it is free of chemicals it does not
contain any chemicals whereas if you see
non-organic food
it is full of chemicals so
it has a threat of adulteration
adulteration and there is also a threat
of chemicals being used
right students organic food is free of
chemicals non-organic food a has a
threat of adulteration and it also has a
threat of chemicals so if many chemicals
are used and if the if there is food
adulteration people who consume it will
fall ill that is certain so that is a
point of comparison between the two
next
continue with question number five
based on your reading of the text
list one benefit of eating organic food
so why do people eat
organic food what is the benefit of
eating organic food
okay now the question is very uh pretty
easy for your understanding and you can
easily answer it
what is the benefit
it is healthy
and safe
OK one benefit is that it is very
healthy and it is very safe and okay you
can also add some reason as it is
naturally grown
as it is ah grown organically
OK it is going to be more safer and
healthier to the people who consume it
so it could be our answer dear students
OK next let's continue with the sixth
question
what connect does the writer draw
between
contamination of food and washing hands
two concepts are given here one is
contamination of food the other one is
washing hands
okay so contamination of food and
washing hands what is the connection
given between these two
so if you wash our hands you know there
is ah always doctor suggest us and we
have already ah we follow this thing we
have heard it
washing hands decreases the
contamination of food
right so what happens when we wash our
hands when we wash our hands before
eating it prevents a certain extent of
contamination of food
washing hands prevents some certain
extent of food contamination
so this is one connection that we can
draw
okay I hope you are you have given this
correct answers dear students
let's go with this seventh question
yes the writer says
that people believe
that it is safer and more nutritious to
eat organic food
select the reason for his skeptical View
okay so the writer says what does the
writer say people believe what do the
people believe it is safer and more
nutritious to eat organic food
okay so people say people believe it's
not like the writer who is believing it
he says people believe that is why the
question is like select the reason for
his skeptical view why is the writer
doubting
okay skeptical no not believing
something not convinced of something now
let's go with the answer
the price decides the popularity
option b there is no confirmed evidence
option C it is tastier
option D it is marketed by big food
companies
okay so now if we say like Y is the
writer skeptical about this the answer
would be simply
what is the answer dear students you
must have already gone with option b
option b there is no confirmed evidence
as there is no confirmed evidence you
know the writer is really skeptical is
doubting
why people believe that it is safer and
more nutritious Even in our reading of
the text we came across
though it is believed there is no
appropriate sufficient confirmed
evidence so option b is the correct
answer for the seventh one
okay
let us continue with the
eighth question
Supply 1.2
Supply one point to justify the
following some people think
organic also means locally grown
have you got this answer dear students
how do you justify this statement some
people think organic also means locally
grown
now the correct answer for this one we
have the situation in the paragraphs
itself
yeah please have a glance at this some
people think organic also means locally
grown and originally it was indeed true
so from this line our answer can be
extracted and our answer is
okay to this question number eight
Supply one point to justify some people
think that organic also means locally
grown because it is indeed true
OK as it is given in the line of the
comprehension we can just say like
because it is true
let's continue with the next question
dear students
Supply One method of how we can control
the contamination of organic food and
non-organic food very important question
and
as it is a non-mcq question you can give
relevant answer for that so you need to
give a method of how we can control the
contamination of organic and non-organic
food what is the answer
we can control the contamination of
organic and non-organic food by reducing
or restricting the usage of chemicals
and pesticides
okay if you have mentioned this phrase
like reduction restriction of the usage
of chemicals and pesticides
in the farming
that is going to be sufficient for the
answer
okay dear students so what is the method
by reducing or restricting the usage of
chemicals and pesticides we can control
the contamination of organic and
non-organic food okay reduction or
restriction of chemicals let's continue
with the tenth one
list one factor that certifies food to
be organic
be organic so did you identify any
Factor dear students
yes any students
fine now the factor is special labels
being attached
if you have mentioned this one in your
answer it's going to be correct special
labels being attached is one factor that
certifies food to be organic special
labels
okay dear students so ah how many of you
are scoring 10 on 10 in this discursive
passage may have your hands raised
or at least some comment Sense on 10 on
10.
how many of you are scoring 10 on 10
if you have given a relevant answer that
is sufficient dear students see for mcqs
you are supposed to give the exact
answer for the non mcqs had you given
the relevant answer
it would be sufficient if you have given
right
how many of you
okay so are you ready to
go with the second passes case based
Passage
let us continue with the second passage
dear students
case based factual Passage
okay before we read that I'm sure you
all have your question paper with you
please have a glance at the uh at that
and let's read it once according to a
new study a vast blanket of pollution
stretching across South Asia is cutting
down sunlight by 10 percent over India
damaging agriculture modifying rainfall
patterns and putting hundreds of
thousands of people at risk
it is said
acids in the Hedge May by Falling as
acid rain have the potential to damage
crops and trees
Ash falling on leaves can aggravate the
impact of reduced sunlight on the
Earth's surface
the pollution that is forming the Hedge
could be leading to several hundreds of
thousands of premature deaths as a
result of higher level of respiratory
diseases
the haze has cut down sunlight over
India by 10 percent so far a huge amount
as a repercussion
the northwest of India is drying up
Professor V ramanathan said when asked
specifically about the impact of the age
of our India he said
we are still in an early stage of
understanding the impact of the Hedge
Professor V ramanathan was asked whether
the current droughts in most parts of
India after over a decade of good
monsoons was going to the Hedge
he said it was too early to reach a
conclusion if the droughts persist for
about four to five years then we would
start suspecting that it may be because
of the Hedge
India China and Indonesia are the worst
affected going to the population density
economic growth and depleting Forest
cover
okay dear students to continue with the
session and to discuss this question
answers I cordial invite
my dear friend Mr moleser to continue
with the proceedings next ones
come sir
thank you Mr charm and my dear favorite
students of uh
pan India in this context I would like
to welcome you to this wonderful you
have had a wonderful session now thanks
to Mr sham regarding discuss your
paragraph okay where you came across 10
Competency Based questions okay the
paper seems to be very easy as long as
set one has been concerned okay so the
thing is that of course you have nailed
it there is no doubt about it okay now
when it comes to case based ah
factual paragraph here also we have been
given 10 questions with the total of
carrying you know 10 Max now I'm sure if
you see ah in this visual inputs point
of view if I check here yeah there was
no visual input if you see throughout
the question paper there are only four
paragraphs and moreover ah as per
expectation in the question number two
we have some visual input okay like a
sort of Mind map okay with the pollution
being the hyper name okay now and fifth
question also carried a sort of pie
chart we can say of course percentage
was not given in over there but
questions are really very easy now if
you see here
um idea students the paragraph began
like this according to a new study a
vast blanket of pollution stretching
across South Asia is cutting down
sunlight by 10 percent over India
damaging agriculture modifying rainfall
as patterns and putting hundreds of
thousands of people at risk so that was
the first era I mean sub paragraph okay
it is said acids in the haze may be
falling in acid rain so it is all about
somewhat we can capture very easily like
climate change
are eco-friendliness it's time we awoke
from our deep Slumber of protecting the
Earth okay or what are the measures to
be taken to safeguard our beautiful this
planet Earth okay so first question if I
welcome you of course you have you have
definitely been carrying your question
papers okay so if you see that like our
usual instruction based on your
understanding of the passage answer the
questions given below
particularly in case based factual
paragraph if you see the world limit 250
around we have to comprehend a lot
because visual inputs are given
okay in bulk we can say or back to back
either if not in paragraph at least it
will be in form of questions all the way
so if you see the first question my dear
friends
in for one reason for the following
based on the information in Paragon so
what was the parable we read it already
isn't it according to a new study new
survey it's a survey based question
info one reason for the following based
on the information in Paragon what is
the question in India rainfall patterns
are changing because because of climate
change then what will the answer okay if
you see the answer here the reason
because infer one reason you have to
draw one reason there can be myriads of
reasons I will be sharing only one
reason because you are at your what you
call Freedom since pollution and
temperature are increasing that's it
okay
because para number one very clearly
states that since pollution and
temperature are increasing in India of
course rainfall patterns are changing
okay
out and out objective paragraph
question two now come to question number
two the pollution spreading across South
Asia is affecting India by what a dash
is followed
yes most of you wrote correct answers if
I see okay I could see your comments
that you're very happy not only in
discursive but also case based factual
paragraphs okay your comments are
clearly telling me that you are very
much happy and you nailed it almost okay
right in India rainfall patterns are
changing over the pollution spreading
across South Asia is affecting India by
what now this here you have you know
again a hyper name with hyponyms
surrounding it if you see in clockwise
direction we have one damaging
agriculture
okay
modifying rainfall pattern putting
people at risk and spoiling blankets
milder children let us not waste time
you have to lock it on option A a Roman
1 Roman 2 and Roman 3 that means
damaging agriculture modifying rainfall
pattern putting people at risk okay
clear that's all so that marks the end
of second question okay right right okay
okay thank you all the best keep it up
now question number three complete the
following analogy correctly with the
words a phrase from para two now here
like you know it is just like a
mathematical equation left hand side
must be equal to right hand side okay
yeah for example um
we can simply just a moment huh yeah
yeah thank you
thank you yeah
and 10th question yeah
okay okay
children so one two and three okay now
when it comes to analogy if you see
analogy basically stands for what
it's just like mathematical equation
left hand side and right hand side so
left hand side what is the pattern we do
not know because that is the question
possibility
is to what when suspecting is to
doubting it means suspect if somebody is
suspecting me obviously somebody is
doubting me so synonyms we have been
expected from thesaurus point of view
the words carrying similar meaning
suspect is equal to doubt suspecting is
equal doubting so possibility then what
is meant by possibility here so we have
to we have been given even a location
also in the paragraph that is paragraph
number two so we can guess for
potentially right okay so potential
being the answer here clear them okay
one second ah let us go with the fourth
question as well immediately in fourth
question we have see synonyms right hand
side so left hand cell also we have to
bring the synonyms again now fourth
select the correct option to complete
the sentence
droughts were caused by the haze
in this you can nail the option at a
strong evidence suggested that what has
suggested strong evidence suggested that
droughts were caused by the haze
okay clear next number five
yeah
we have now from the following pie chart
identify one reason each which does
and does not contribute to weather this
disruption it's a very simple question
only though pie chart has been given
once we go through the entire paragraph
it becomes very clear for example now if
you see from the following pie chart let
us identify one reason each which does
or does not contribute to whether
disruption means that is completely
alien in this segment for example
ah weather is disrupted of course
because of
organic farming definitely not okay that
will not support our answer isn't it so
it's very clear because others are
almost we can say you know in negative
mode so positive mode it's not an issue
right next we have for the visually
impaired candidates also in lieu of
question number uh the fifth one for
example list two phenomena which lead to
weather disruptions again we can go with
excessive extreme temperatures and
excessive pollution
now your favorite question again mcqs
number six fill in the blank by
selecting
the correct option now children Ash
falling on leaves can Dash the impact of
reduced sunlight on the Earth's surface
what seems to be the right answer now
you can guess
there there is a person B encourage C
diminish and D support so you can go
with first one version Ash falling and
leaves can worsen can only damage
okay the scenario the impact of reduced
sunlight on the Earth's surface okay
that match the end of the sixth question
in this regard okay number seven you
have
understood the word repercussion
seems to be rather simple right with one
word similar in meaning
in the following sentence from para
three location is very clearly given
geographical location matters a lot in
this concept context okay subterras are
there whether it's discursive case based
normally dear children we have to
completely have our focus on that
particular locations of Paris so here
given surprise number three okay if you
can see there okay for example the sub
pair of given ok so the answer you can
make make it very clear that
has cut down sunlight or India
as the repercussion the northwest of
India is drying up
so obviously repercussion stands for
consequence or effects results outcomes
effects we can call or any other
relevant answer okay right
just a moment we have some technical
support here
so list any two countries which are
affected due to depleting Forest cover
the forest has been fast
ah we can say
depleted OK time and again so which are
those two countries now if you take for
example yeah very good I think this is
much better position from mind
I will give you two examples based on
your para Indonesia as well as China
okay South East Asian countries you can
go even for more number of countries
with the help of the para or based on
your common sense okay but since we have
to stick to the para let us go with
Indonesia and China okay very good next
which of the following mean the same as
persist in drafts droughts persist
as used in para4 okay so we have
question papers they definitely have a
glance at it so persist in the sense
continue
okay
continue that becomes your C answer C
for continue next
final final round of final tenth
question you have got very good which
are uh yeah 10th question select the
option yeah it's under display ah
select the option that titles paragraphs
one to four appropriately with reference
to information in the text minded
children this is a very very
simple question given by the word I can
say because already on 16 September when
sample question paper pattern was
released in that case based factual
paragraph 10th question if you see
similar type of question so this is
definitely not an alien or foreign one
for you you can definitely achieve it if
you see if you ask me now based on the
first force of Paras ah yeah select the
option that titles
titles carry sub theme okay so para one
two four appropriately with reference to
the information in the text will be
option A you can mark it option here how
many of you wrote
almost okay you nailed it so a option it
uh if you see new there are two rounds I
can say alphabetical as well as
numerical so a option you have chosen so
first one in that becomes impact of
pollution in South Asia
then effects of acid rain understanding
consequences of phase and debate old
routes clear so a option has been your
right answer okay
yeah we have
once again have a glance at this okay
very clear now dear children if you see
here
first answer we are choosing
the reason behind you know first sub
paragraph speaks about speaks volumes
about effect up pollution in South Asia
then we have effects of acid rain
then we have understanding consequences
of phase and debate or drugs okay
clear okay
okay
just a moment now so that all the four
options will be visible if I change my
position from there to here
Okay so
with reference to the information given
in the text if you see all the four
Paras this will be matching in much
proper we call you know details clear
them okay right with that that marks the
end of case-based factual paragraph let
me invite Mr sham once again
foreign Mr kissing Mr kissing is a mass
teacher that is not mentioned
let's continue dear students
let us continue dear students with
grammar
I am sure that you have answered well
and
as the instruction of the question says
attempt any ten of the following 12 you
must have answered 12 and you're very
sure certain that you are going to get
10 on 10. yes
good really all your hard work that you
have put in for this exam has come ah
with all of its result in favor of UDS
students the first question
the teacher motivated the students by
letting them know that if they Dash
submit their assignments by the end of
the day they might get an opportunity to
watch the match
now
is it option A did not
or option b must option C word option D
work
okay what do you think is the option
here students
option C is the correct answer so the
teacher said
the teacher said
the teacher motivated the students by
letting them know that if they would
submit their assignments by the end of
the day they might get an opportunity to
watch the match
it's like conditional clause
so we need to go with the uh the past
one something that is like wood no it
shows the past
let's go with the second one read the
conversation between a coach and this
player complete the sentence by
reporting the players reply correctly
coach
will you be able to report for morning
practice during the summer break
player sir I will report every morning
at 7am Short
now the dialogue
the coach while
trying to while talking to the player
asked him
whether he would be able to report for
morning practice
the player Affirmed
okay that's where our our answer needs
to be continued the player Affirmed
okay dear students you know that this is
an assertive sentence I will report
every morning at 7 AM sharp so we are
going to start it with our answer begins
with the connecting word that the player
affirmed that I will report every
morning so it is simple future with Will
so that would be changed into
I that pronoun I will be changed into he
will report it will be changed into good
report every morning at 7 AM sharp that
would be the answer to your students the
player affirmed that he would report
every morning at 7 AM Sharp
yes third one select the correct option
to fill in the blank for the given line
from a daily newspaper
so this question is taken from uh the
line of a newspaper what is it the cars
were stopped Dash going any further due
to a terrific diversion
of course we know that the given options
indicate a preposition
though we are not suggested we are not
prescribed by the board for preposition
as a topic we are
we have already learned right and it
comes from a daily life situations the
cards were stopped to going any further
from going any further with him going
any further by going any further
okay so now here the answer what is it
what is the correct answer dear students
what do you think is the answer
okay the answer is B
correct answer is BDA students from the
cars were stopped from going any further
due to a traffic diversion
yes continue with the next question
fourth one year students
Crazy Action
select the option that identifies the
error and supplies the correction for
the following traffic advisory
now this is the statement whoever drove
a motor vehicle without a safety belt or
carries
passengers without seat belts will be
fined
okay now the answer would be like drove
or drives whoever drove
a motor vehicle without a safety belt or
carries a passenger without seat belt
will be find option b or or nor
option C without or within option D find
or celebrated
okay option A will be the correct answer
dear students whoever drove a motor
vehicle is incorrect okay option A is
the correct answer whoever drives you
have another clue in this one you see
whoever drove a motor vehicle without a
safety belt
now if you just concentrate on row it is
in simple past tense and if you see
carries it is in simple present tense
right and it is also like a traffic
advisory which Remains the Same
so there shall be no no need of any ah
simple past verb so we can just go ahead
with the present verb only that is why
whoever drives a motor vehicle without a
safety belt or carries passengers
without seat belts will be fine so that
will be our answer
let's continue with the fifth question
dear students
there
fifth one
complete the given narrative by
filling in the blank with the correct
option
not only did mayank work hard to win the
trophy
helped the Juniors to improve their
skills okay so here before help there is
a blank not only did man work to
win the trophy
okay we we are very familiar with this
usage whenever we have not only we need
to have a correspondence correlative
conjunction okay
can not only
mayank work hard to win the trophy
Dash is here
he as well as helped but but he also
helped and he also or just he we know
that when we have not only we need to
have a phrase with her but also
so but he also helped the Juniors to
improve their skills so option b is the
correct answer for question number five
let's continue with question number six
fill in the blank by using the correct
form of the word given in the brackets
the names of the applicants
were
Dash is given here
the names of the applicants were Dash
in the report and submit submitted to
the manager the names of the applicants
were okay in Brackets we have this word
listed okay what is the answer now list
so if you go with the names of the
applicants for listing then it is
incorrect because names
they cannot list themselves that will be
active wise so dear students you need to
go with the passive form here the names
of the applicants were listed in the
report and submitted to the manager so
the correct answer is listed
please note this one listed is the
correct answer
yes so that is a further sixth one let's
go with the seventh one
right
is it
the seventh question dear students
complete the sentence with the
appropriate option
two-thirds of the students
we have a blank here
oh
two-thirds of the students
Dash present at the inaugural function
so this comes under subject verb
agreement this is one topic which we
have learned very keenly and the options
two-thirds of the students is present at
the inaugural ceremony
being present at the inaugural function
was present at the inaugural function
were present at the inaugural function
what do you think is the answer dear
students a b c d which one is the answer
in case you are going with option A
like two-thirds of the students is
present then why not was because time
factor is not given of course being
present
it's not
appropriate in this sentence because it
cannot play the role of a main verb so
two-thirds of the students it is the
plural two-thirds of the students is a
plural so since the subject of this
sentence is plural we need to go with
option b work two thirds of the students
were present at the inaugural function
so option D is the answer the students
Mark your answers
foreign
question number
eight
identify the error on a Shop's holding
and Supply the correction
now this is given uh which travels
private limited these poor Savannah
let's read the information given in the
content of the question for travel
informations contact the 24 hours help
desk
for travel informations contact the 24
hour help desk
so dear students we know that
information is incorrect
it is always in a singular form OK we we
have to say like for travel information
so the correction takes place like
informations is error and its correction
is information
so how many of you mark this one as the
correct one check yourself
ninth one
select the correct option to complete
the narration of the dialog between Ajay
and his friend
Ajay did you buy a zoom lens with your
camera
Ajay no I did not I ran out of money
ajay's friend asked Ajay whether he had
bought a zoom lens with his camera
Ajay replied that he had not because
so dear students you need to choose the
correct answer I ran out of money for
that sentence you need to supply the
correct reported speech that's it I ran
out of money
past tense we know that simple past
changes to past perfect tense so in the
given options we need to identify where
we have a clause showing
past perfect tense I ran out of money
like had run out of money we need to
check
okay let me repeat the sentence
whether he had bought a zoom lens with
his camera
Ajay replied that he had not
because he was running out of money he
has run out of money he have run out of
money he had run out of money
so out of all these ABCD options a b c
are incorrect
option D is the answer he had run out of
money
he had run out of many option D is the
correct answer
next
10th one
fill in the blank by choosing the
correct option
his brother
along with his friends leaving for the
stadium
this is also another question that comes
under subject verb agreement his brother
along with his friends
are leaving for the stadium has living
for the stadium is leaving for the
stadium were leaving for the stadium so
which one do you think is the correct
answer
option A B C D which one do you think is
the answer
option A is the correct answer dear
students
his brother is the main subject in that
so his brother
along with his friends
we have learned in subject verb
agreement okay the phrase which follows
like along and so on is not a part of
the subject what is placed before these
words along with or in addition to OK
those words what is placed before them
is the subject so here his brother is
the subject of my sentence so his
brother is singular I need to have like
his brother is leaving for the stadium
ok so if you take like his brother along
with his friends you may be confused you
may go with the r that is incorrect his
brother is leaving okay his brother
along with his friends is leaving for
the stadium so that is question number
10.
let's continue with question number 11.
the residents promised okay complete the
given narrative by filling in the blank
with the correct option
the residents promised to dash the
president of the association in his
demand for proper Garbage Disposal
Systems
now the options are
the residents promised to stood by the
residents promised to stand by
the promise the residents promised to
stand against the president
the residents promised to stood for the
president
now out of these options ABCD
you know we can just looking at the
sentence structure Itself by looking at
the word to before the blank we can rule
out option A we can also roll out option
D because they mismatch
they are not correct in that context
okay two stood by or to to stood for
both are incorrect now we are only left
with to stand by to stand against
only these two are like you know you
need to consider and out of this if you
are considering
to stand by or to stand against we have
to go with to stand by you know they are
ready to follow him to support him or no
to be with him fight for him or for the
cause common cause so the residents
promised to stand by option b is the
correct answer
registered
okay dear students so
you have noted I believe
for the 11th one
answer stand by is the correct one
option b
let's continue with the 12th one
fill in the blank with the correct
option
the number of people
attending this evening's annual function
is Dash then that of the previous years
if you just see this one it's like you
know degrees of comparison is tested
here dear students see both is very
clever it has only given us five topics
prescribed five topics but it is it is
testing as inactive passive voice now in
this question it is testing us in a
degrees of comparison
in the previous editing we came across
even it has tested related to
preposition topics also in a way
everything see when we learn English we
learn integrated grammar it's not just
those topics alone right so let us apply
for this thing our English knowledge the
number of people attending this
evening's annual function is Dash than
that of the previous years
now there is a comparison between the
number of people attending between this
year this evening's annual function and
that of the last year so previous years
so in the brackets there is a clue for
you to choose the word
which is suitable as a comparative
degree
okay so now you see function is fewer
than fewer than less than much than
so if you see all these ABCD dear
students you are only left with option A
you're only left with option A
which means
the students option here that is the
correct answer for us
fewer than we know it no that is the
correct answer
next later I come coming to the second
one
from this one we have another
in section B we have like second section
second part of section B writing attempt
anyone from A and B given below
you have Mohit or mohita of E46
you came across news articles about
neglect of Elders in today's society
Disturbed after reading the Articles you
decide to write a letter to the editor
of the Hindustan times
stressing upon the need of sensitizing
children to The Plight and loneliness of
the elders and to inculcate in them
values of caring and sharing you can
also express your views on strengthening
of family values write your letter in
100 to 120 words so this letter to
editor
okay he is supposed to be addressed to
the editor of the Hindustan times and
what is the uh what could be the subject
line of this letter strengthening of a
family values
you know we this is again a topic which
is very familiar to you I'm sure you
would have applied you have applied the
correct format you know begin with the
after mentioning the exact question
number Sunday's address space date
receivers address subject line
salutation
then go with first paragraph
introduction second paragraph body of
the letter the third paragraph
conclusion so while writing this body of
the letter you know you need to
highlight how ah the values are
decreasing in the people today
they are neglecting the parents due to
various causes you could mention a few
causes that makes the people that make
the people to forget their parents or
devalue their parents and you know there
is an increased number of voltage homes
you could even mention that as your
Value Point
and what else could be done
or by the respective Editor to teach
these kind of moral values to the people
that would strengthen them
morally
that would strengthen their family
values so if you could specify all these
kind of value points in your letter I'm
sure you are going to get good score for
that
in fourth B we have something like you
are rajini or Rakesh kothari director
Marketing in oil spices manufacturing
unit
you have observed the commitment with
which your assistant manager works write
a letter in 100 to 120 words to your
assistant manager sadika Qureshi
congratulating him on his work ethic and
professional approach
also include a mention of his commitment
sense of responsibility good
interpersonal skills and his Spirit of
teamwork really it's a very good kind of
letter dear students to say you know you
are like writing this letter as a
manager
of a company like oil spices
manufacturing unit and you are writing
it to the assistant manager who has been
very sincere committed dedicated towards
his uh professional approach in the work
field okay so it is always good that you
highlight you notice the hard work of
such people and the right
as a manager now while writing this one
you may
describe indeed some of the professional
qualities required for any person in any
profession
now how this particular assistant
manager is fulfilling this
highlight if you if you can create if
you could create any a few instances
that would be very better in your answer
right okay fine you go ahead like this
that would be sufficient for that let's
go with the next question dear students
fifth one a
pie chart is given to us ill treatment
of animals
it is distressing to see the attitude of
people towards animals the number of
cases of Cruelty towards animals is
increasing the following pie chart
represents the attitude of people
towards animals write an analytical
paragraph in 100 to 120 words
interpreting the data given in the pie
chart so in this one we have like ill
treatment of animals
three spheres are given self-interest no
longer useful physical abuse indifferent
attitude so you have practiced writing
analytical paragraph based on this one
so while writing a little paragraph also
we need to have on an appropriate
introduction and a relevant body with
some facts and figures and you need to
analyze the data given here and they are
also a requisite of giving a proper
conclusion so if you have written all
these within the word limit of 100 to
120 that would be sufficient
thank you
next B study the bar chart given below
the chart depicts the number of students
in class 12 opting for humanities
science and commerce streams in urban
and rural areas based on the details
given in the bar chart given below write
an analytical paragraph in 100 to 120
words
okay see these questions what we have
seen in analytical paragraph
both A and B are quite different from
what we have seen in the sqp
sample question paper given by the board
in Sample equation paper given by the
board board asked us to express your
stand but here in this particular board
paper what we got today in set one we
don't see any kind of argumentative
analytical paragraph they are only
asking you to just analyze the paragraph
which is given okay so we have learned
how an analytical paragraph should have
should be written
introduction body and conclusion if you
have followed this criteria that would
be enough dear students
now the most interesting section for you
people all and the section which
requires lot of ah
you know you have put in lot of hard
work going through the textbook only for
this section c section c literature I am
sure even in this section also you have
attempted well and you have scored full
marks anyway let's just have a glance at
each question and continue with that
there are you know we identify number of
changes in the question paper we
received today and in the sqp we
received in the past
you know when we received sqp sample
question paper by the board after giving
us an extract they used to mention the
name of the question uh from where uh it
is given
this phrase I'm sorry I didn't get you
missed seventh part what does it mean
okay
let's continue with section c
literature question number six a
I wrote the three pages
Mr K casing had assigned me and was
satisfied
I argued that
talking is a student Street and that I
would do my best to keep it under
control but that I would never be able
to cure myself of the habit since my
mother talked as much as I did if not
more and that there is not much one can
do about inherited traits so this is
taken from the dairy of Anna Frank
lesson
yeah we will continue with set two right
now we have set one we will continue
with the set two later dear students
now the first question who was Mr casing
the option A
it is given as English teacher option b
social science teacher option C Warden
option D principal
okay I am sure as we go through the
lesson we never come across like Mr
casing is as like English teacher or a
social science teacher or a warden or a
principal
right so we actually learned in the
lesson that Mr casing is a mathematics
teacher
so no answer is given hopefully Grace
Mark is going to be awarded for all the
students uh when it is like six a one
let's continue with six uh A2 dear
students let's go with 6A
2.
what do we have in six ea2 according to
the extract The encourageable Habit
possessed by the speaker was
making noise in class talking too much
procrastinating coming late to class
asking irritating questions so which one
do you think is the correct one select
the correct option
according to the extract the
incorrigible habit possessed by the
speaker something that the speaker
cannot come out
cannot stop
okay so making noise in class talking
too much procrastinating coming late to
class
like asking irritating questions so if
you see option b only two okay something
that the uh
only two is the answer dear students
what do we have like only two talking
too much is the incorrigible habit
possessed by the speaker
the third question
select the option
that correctly captures the application
of the word fire as used in this extract
pardon me
third question is related to
analogy complete the analogy by
selecting the suitable word from the
extract
now
the very first pair of words routine
habit
okay routine habit okay so what do we
understand something we do regularly is
routine and that becomes a habit now we
need to identify something like for
characteristic a synonym which would be
sufficient suitable and that too as the
instruction of the question says we need
to identify from the extract itself so
in the extract we came across in line
second line itself I argued that talking
is a student straight so characteristic
it goes with the answer treat
and characteristic both are similar next
question number four select the reason
why the narrator is unable to control
her trait yeah you have studied this
question dear students you have answered
it number of times why is it that Mr uh
why is it that Annie Frankie is unable
to stop her
talkative nature or talking too much why
is she like that
she had deliberately practiced it she
wanted to be different from her brother
her teacher had encouraged her to
continue as she was
and option D she had inherited it so we
have it directly from the extract itself
the last line says
and that there is not much one can do
about inherited traits
so she means to say that in the previous
line
I would never be able to cure myself of
the habit since my mother talked as much
as I did so option D
is the correct one what is that option
this is she had inherited it
so this is the correct answer dear
students next fifth one which of the
following most nearly means the opposite
of the phrase and the control
which of the following most nearly means
the opposite of the phrase under control
to spend less
unable to take on the challenge
find it difficult to manage
being very stubborn so now the options
suggest us to go with option C find it
difficult to manage
under control is the expression given
okay for the word for the phrase under
control we are supposed to choose the
antonym opposite so find it difficult to
manage is opposite to under control you
know under control means you find it
easy to manage
but opposite you find it difficult to
manage so this is what right from six a
six year first one we may have some
Grace mark because casing is a maths
teacher but other other than that the
remaining four like B
second one B is the answer third trait
fourth one D is the answer fifth one C
is the answer
let us continue with the sixth b d h
students
his landlord disliked him and tried to
eject him
in Revenge Griffin Set Fire to the house
to get away without being seen he had to
remove his clothes
thus it was that he became a homeless
Wanderer
without clothes without money and quite
invisible until he happened to step in
some mud and left Footprints as he
walked now this is taken from Footprints
without feet your favorite lesson and in
the recent sample paper for practice
practice question paper given by the
board even in that also we could see a
comprehension taken from this lesson
right
landlord tried to eject him because
try to eject you know try to send him
out so why did he liked why why what
made him or what compel the landlord to
send him out or to eject him because
option A he was the Lawless person
option b he had set his house on fire
option C he did not like him option D he
was a drug addict
ok ok dear students in this we may we
have to go with option A he was a
lawless person
foreign
Griffin
he was a lawless person
yes next second one
fill in the blank with one word only
Griffin deliberately removed his clothes
because he wanted to become
become what
okay we may go with this word invisible
okay throughout the lesson we see this
one no he worked hard for getting this
uh
skill or getting this done like being
invisible
so Griffin deliberately removed is close
because he wanted to become invisible
so that people cannot find out like
where he is and who he is
third question select the option that
correctly captures the application of
the word fire as used in this extract
Griffin said that option a griffin said
that he would fire the manager
option b the soldiers opened fire at the
enemy
option C his remarks provoked heavy fire
from the political opponents
option D the Amma Palace was completely
destroyed by the fire so if you see the
application of the word fire in the
context
it is just like this
okay so from the context we have to
understand the students like
option
D is the correct answer the Amma Palace
was completely destroyed by the fire so
if you see option A B C like he would
fire the manager like he would send him
out rule him out or terminate him that
would be the meaning the soldiers opened
fire at the enemy that is something
referring to military base
okay next if you see option C
like provoked heavy fire like
provocation
like it made them to speak more about it
okay but whereas if you see the option D
it is also like destruction of the
palace by using fire and it uh ah it is
suitable to the context that we have in
the comprehension
fourth one Griffin's presence was felt
when
okay
so third one and our answer would be D
fourth
Griffin's presence was felt when he
jumped into the water with a splash
when he wore clothes
when he left muddy Footprints when he
stepped in mud
so here
we according to the lesson we can go
with option C when he left muddy
footprints
leaving muddy footprints
next fifth one
which of the following is not true with
reference to the given extract
Griffin had become penniless Griffin
promised to behave himself Griffin
revealed himself by his muddy Footprints
no one could see Griffin when he took
off his clothes
so which is not true
option a CD they are all true according
to the lesson so we are only left with a
option b
what is that Griffin promised
to behave himself
it is it is something that we never come
across in the lesson
so
for this sixth B like first one answer
is a he was the lowest person second one
word is invisible third one option D
fourth one C fifth one b
let's continue with seventh Year dear
students
or if sometime when roaming round a
noble wild beast greets you with black
stripes on yellow ground and just notice
if he hits you this simple rule may help
you learn the Bengal tiger to discern
now this is taken like from what uh how
to tell wild animals
now in this the first question
who is the noble wild beast in the above
lines
so in the stanza what I read to you we
have an animal a beast described
Asian tiger Asian line Bengal tiger so
the first one answer is
it is Bengal tiger I put it like BT
second one
it is clear that alliteration is the
poetic device used for roaming round
because
now you need to explain how all
iteration X applies here
we have learned it well okay so roaming
ground
this alliteration why because the
repetition of
R sound is seen in the given expression
or in the neighboring words that would
be sufficient students repetition of a r
sound in the neighboring words
because of the repetition of R sound in
the neighboring words
let's go with
the third one state whether the
following statement is true or false
they extract helps to identify a Royal
Bengal Tiger
yes
yeah in the throughout the standard we
see and in the last time there is a
special mention of Bengal tiger so the
answer would be true
fourth one
in the given lines what effect does the
poet create
just notice if he hits you
this simple rule may help you learn the
Bengal tiger 2 discern
so what what what is the device that the
poet is using and its effect
it's like Ina option A is the correct
one year students
Terror sympathy criticism
they don't match
fifth one which word in the extract
tells you that you have recognized the
noble Beast
option a rule option b design option C
roaming option D notice so fifth one
option
B design
the meaning of the word discern is
nothing but
like
recognizing something that you have
recognized the noble base that you have
discerned and if you if you are not sure
also if you know the meaning of ACD you
will understand like they are not pretty
clear
okay uh
apart from this
we have like question number eight nine
ten eleven answer any of four of the
following questions in about 40 to 50
words
what is the Indian legend about the
discovery of T we have the clear answer
from uh the glimpse of India tea from
Assam
then what did lencho hope for and why
what did he offer he hoped for some
money from God and why because he had
lost his crop
which he thought would give him some
money that would be sufficient for the
survival of the family so he missed it
so you could mention that in your answer
I'll take the risk
take it it is asked from the black
airplane the narrator wanted to take
risk he knows that the weather is not
Cooperative even then he wants to take a
risk of going
by you know using his uh Dakota
next what impression do you form about
Amanda in the poem
Amanda what kind of girl is Amanda
The Silent Girl calm girl she's a girl
who fantasizes about the things
she's an unhappy girl with the
continuous instructions or nagging from
the guardian
we could give such kind of answer and we
also can say like she's a girl who lacks
Freedom or who really wants to or who
craves for Freedom that also could be an
answer
next what did Siddhartha Gautama come
across by chance when he was about 25
years old
we know that all the four instances
okay the site of a sick man an old man
okay a sage asking for arms begging
forearms and all these
will help us to give you the correct
answer and out of these five all the
five are direct question answers from
our book only you should have cracked
them well
ninth one answer any two of the
following questions in about 40 to 50
words each it is from supplementary
reader how did harising justify to
himself he's stealing anil's money
ok so that is also from the lesson next
how did upright's Mother help him to
become a scientist
so being uh not just a mother but being
a companion being a friend being a
teacher a provider all those like how
she has supplied all the equipment he
needs all the play items he needs and
such items are also going to improve his
intelligence is interest in the
collection of butterflies
so that's how she is she has not just
played the role of a mother but also the
role of a teacher a friend a guide all
that we can write why was Mr Harriet
shocked at tricky's appearance
okay why was he shocked because it grew
more than it is supposed to be according
to its age
and we know what made the tricky to grow
like that and how did Harriet read that
also we know you could mention that
makes long answers dear students
10 to 1 a the people and surroundings
are a great book to learn from only in
the lesson Madam writes the bus learns a
lot from others mention the traits of a
character which help her to learn from
people and her surroundings wali's role
from Madame raised the bus she is a girl
curious Girl full of enthusiasm
he was always eager to know
especially about the bus ride right so
we could give the character sketch of a
Wali from Madame rides the bus and hope
you have highlighted the quality of
learning from people and surroundings
that is important she continuously heard
from others and that's how her Reagan
has increased it it become like a
burning desire after hearing
next B Mandela said people must learn to
hate and if they can learn to hate they
can be taught to love
okay this is also taken from Nelson
Mandela long walk to Freedom so it's not
that you have to love alone but people
must learn to hate so if you know how it
hated affects then you may know the
value the depth of love the effect love
creates next level
is disposition invites a doom illustrate
with reference to the text so how Mrs
ma'am loisal suffered if she is
suffering today what led her her desires
our financial state are not okay not
being happy with what she had her
husband's position all these things
trouble her and that's the reason she
really suffers now her Doom
just mention all these from the
reference of the text
11th bolivas believed to be a dumb cow
what turned her into a Fearless bold and
confident girl so we see how uh bully
she was called as suleka at that initial
stage parents call her like Bully she
was like a dumb cow and afterwards when
she once she gets into school and
education she becomes she turns into a
Fearless bold and confident girl so you
can quote some of the references from
the textbook and support your answer so
dear students this is all the paper I'm
sure all of you have cracked it because
many questions seem to be direct and
easy except one or two
okay how many of you are scoring 40 on
40 especially in discussive case based
grammar and extracts how many of you are
scoring 40 on 40 is there anyone
so if there is anyone who is scoring 40
on 40 there
there is a possibility for that student
to score even 80 on 80. that's it with
all
the set one dear students now let's
continue with the set two I invite our
amol sir to continue with the session on
set to key discussion
welcome sir
okay all the best
sorry sorry
foreign that channel
yeah children uh again welcome back with
the set too
now you'll be surprised to know that C2
is also rather easy of course that one
was easy no doubt about it set to C3 are
also very easy in fact most of the
questions are repeated because the ratio
which the board has taught to maintain
80 20 has been completely followed okay
in fact it is over crossing the limit as
well so you're very very fortunate to
have for having gone through such a
wonderful
sets of question papers of English now
when it comes to the discursive
paragraph
you will be surprised to know
because it was all about avalanches
I mean snowfall
the very first line which states that if
you are like most kids for example
normally accidents are of myriad types
man-made
natural calamities Etc so when we
directly come to the business here if
you see the
passage here for example
you see the first question now okay
first question my dear children
um
yeah yeah
so first question if you see
you can just make a note of it
new snow
are rain new snow or rain so the option
here you can say
since we have been given multiple
options of course 4 mcqs are given so it
is very clear that we will be going with
option A
so new
snow
are rain or and rain it's a very simple
one okay based on the location subscribe
one two three four these questions have
been asked so Avalanches basically they
because they use last to life okay next
thing we have
you can see here very clearly
on the screen
second question was asked like this
comment on warning signs
exist which allow experts to predict
avalanches in two sentences now if you
ask me my two sentences will be like
this okay ah
first let me tell you orally you can
capture most of the words okay when
over a foot of fresh snow falls
over a foot okay suppose if I write like
this when
over
a footer
when over a foot of snow falls exactly
what happens we continue
that Avalanches may happen
secondly
if the moving snow gathers a speed of 80
miles per hour
that also becomes a sign so these are
the two signs one is the measure I mean
length of the snow
secondly the speed
with which
the snow moves through so this become
actually the answer for this second okay
Avalanches so we have to be very careful
what is the number three if you see
children ah
third one we have got
[Music]
um
answers like this Avalanches snowfall
and earthquakes these are the basic
reasons OK because the question was
given mention any two reasons mention
two reasons which destroyed the natural
uh scenery nature gets disturbed because
of avalanches
as per the book I mean as per the
question paper
okay second one is
ah snowfall
another one is
we can call Quakes I mean earthquakes
okay these are the three words to be put
under the caption I mean question number
three well it is fourth question if you
see
um select the option that conveys the
opposite of massive and you have got the
options very simple a tiny B Leni C
bulky D extensive b c d you know
actually the meaning is very pretty
clear you can see
ah oppose it whenever you go for
opposites okay antonyms massive very big
and Tiny becomes very small so for
example your answer becomes tiny okay
answer will be tiny ah just let me write
down here a
okay if you allow me to move little
faster then the picture will be very
clear about this discursive paragraph
the
then is paragraph four so in that the
sentence will be taken as a okay people
caught in the Avalanche can try to swim
to the top very clearly it has been
given in paragraph four you have got
question paper set to all those who have
got set to okay you can see that okay
swimming to the top that direction
definitely will carry you marks okay
right yes of course the answers are same
in set three for certain questions okay
not definitely not for all okay right
next we have sixth question select the
option that correspondence corresponds
uh in the just a moment if you see now
sixth question sixth question
what exactly it has stated
select the option that corresponds to
the following relation below
what is that relation for example
okay that is nothing but you may not
have an idea of which way
in up and which way in down there is
also an analogy OK not in form of
equation but in form of theme you know
up is One Direction down is the another
two opposite directions it means two
opposite words are taken into
consideration so similarly the crowd
will gather at gate number one and
disperse from gate number two so
Gathering and dispersing seem to be two
opposite words so pattern has been
captured okay now you can see improviser
due to the torrential rain there was a
heavy flooding
torrential is also bulky heavy so heavy
flooding so both are same going in the
same direction okay ascending order we
can say okay next one the guest okay
what is it uneasy and uncomfortable in
this line uneasy uncomfortable both are
same okay but do not seem to be antonyms
okay next the more the effort the bigger
the more the direction no in ascending
only so that's why we have to choose the
answer a gather and disperse two
opposite directions okay it means they
are doing they are playing the role of a
pair of antonyms okay so option A
becomes the correct answer now be very
careful about this
this is the correct answer because their
people are gathering
okay
and that is exactly is the opposite of
disperse yes or no and how do we get
this answer because it is very simple in
the question we have got you know up and
down this is the hint given to us okay
up is exactly
the opposite of down so option we have a
gather and it suppose it is disperse
clear then sixth question no problem
whereas in B there is no possibility
torrential heavy floating both are same
acting like synonyms next one we have
number seven the major
cars which do not trigger an avalanche
be careful which do not trigger okay not
that which exactly triggers okay which
do not trigger if you see the options
now here very carefully earthquake
normally triggers there is a chance okay
there is a moment okay snowfall of
course it causes rain also then the
plastic waste okay so that is why D will
be the answer for the question number
seven that is plastic waste okay it does
not trigger an avalanche okay clear okay
then we have
next query here ah
this we have to go you know in oral this
one
explosive can be used in places
explosives can be used in places for
example with massive snow buildup
wherever there is huge snow accumulated
we can go with explosives because ah
they will trigger smaller Avalanches so
the dis damage also will be small the
magnitude of the damage will also be
small it is purely ah paragraph oriented
so no problem next we have number ninth
question if you see children the word
deadly in the para 3 most nearly means
now if we see
the word in Para 3 deadly deadly in the
sense if you see
all the people some people some people
will definitely die that para in fact
earns on that note those who are unlucky
they will definitely die of it so it
means the answer is likely to cause
death so deadly is nothing but that
which
causes death that which causes death so
causing death we can say here for
example
in this category yeah a option we can
make use of the word deadly in the para
3 most nearly means likely to cause
death clear then we have
select the most suitable title for the
above passage even
16 September sample question paper case
this factual paragraph 10th question had
this answer but we have to identify all
the four or three titles isn't it but
here we are supposed to go with only one
so you can go here for the 10th question
I mean 10th option for example if you
see here
Avalanche okay we there is no it's not
an adventure with snow definitely not
there is no ice game discussed Calamity
we can't say that because
of course casualties are there it is
very deadly it's okay but overall it is
speaking volumes about Avalanche so let
us go with option A that is Avalanche
okay children so it's clear okay
now we will go with without wasting time
let's go ahead with our case based
factual paragraph okay here we go with
that okay now if you see the first one
ah just a moment yeah
since
you because we are running short of time
so definitely I will be directly taking
you with the answers okay so info
one reason for example
one is in for infer in the sense what is
your reason according to you so we'll
I'll directly announce it
since it is enormous and a stupendous
task
first answer okay since it is enormous
and since it is non McQ as well answer
lies in Parable and that clearly states
it's enormous and stupendous task second
answer that is B B has you know one and
five for example increase in demand for
cars and then we have number five
emission of pollutants these are the two
reasons responsibles ok then we have
number three now question number three
in this regard from case based factual
para be careful children okay number
three
what is expected from us this is the
answer actually highest
whatever the visual input
there or not but it is very clear that
highest becomes the answer analogy
visual input in the sense I was talking
about analogy organized chaotic lowest
highest because organized is the
opposite of chaotic
that's why lowest becomes highest if you
check your left hand side
OK left hand side is given like this you
know organized chaotic so antonyms are
expected
similarly towards right hand side also
antonyms we can expect ok so right hand
side also should have so already lowest
is given so definitely we will go with
highest clear so the answer is question
number three is highest clue is also
given just as organized is an antonym of
chaotic lowest is an antonym of we can
call highest clearance high and low are
two opposites next we are number four
the vehicles emit pollutants which
affect
Public Health badly it's a common sense
actually we need not worry anybody can
get this answer that public health is
badly affected by the pollutants
okay so that becomes your question
number four next we have question number
five complete the following sentences
use a public transport what exactly does
it will
come on yes yes
your comment
okay
yes yes
you will get definitely marks don't
worry okay no need to panic very good
the vehicles emit pollutants which
affect Public Health badly completely
the following sentence use a public
transport will definitely reduce traffic
jumps on roads
user public transport like your bus or
Metro local trains mmts etcetera that
will
reduce
what you call traffic jams okay on those
most of the bottlings are present there
okay next question number six you have
option D that is one
uh and three for example if you see one
is start carpooling and third one
increase in public modes of Transport
carpooling Is Not A New Concept and
thanks to this paragraph We have
understood it very clearly okay then we
have the question dear children that is
seventh one based on of course on a
visual input what is given there analyze
the status of traffic between the years
2019 to 2022 in this if you see that
becomes your question number seventh
what's my input here in the year 2019 it
was recorded 56 percent
where in 2022 there was a decrease that
mean it has come up to 51 so 2019 56
whereas 2022 it becomes 51 percent is
clear and second reason
for
visual impaired children you can go for
people's discipline and their
awareness is very important in this
regard so as to reduce traffic
queries traffic related issues then we
have number eight now number eight
question if you see children ah what is
there here
come on number eight
question raised here is again
ah just a moment let us jump to the next
slide give the reasons for increase in
vehicular congestion vehicular
congestion so first one people
preferring their own vehicles
rather than public transport first
reason Okay so
Every Man Has a car
okay peoples we can say lavish lifestyle
we can say people's lavishness
second one most of the people are
migrating towards
cities so there is an explosion in the
population of cities means urbanization
is under rise so migration to the cities
so population exploitation will also
lead to traffic jams OK and number ninth
is very clear there though doesn't seem
to be any competency but the question is
fill in the blank by selecting correct
option there are Dash consequences of
increasing vehicular
congestion OK when we killer when
vehicles on the road increase definitely
is not beneficial it is not explicit not
implicit but there will be adverse
consequences okay very dire consequences
we can say so number nine will go with
the option b that is adverse
consequences in the sense result here
right
then number two substitute the
underlying word with one word similar in
meaning in the following sentence
citizens of Delhi or national capital
religion region have time and time again
pondered over the possibilities of how
to reduce traffic congestion my dear
children here you have lots of chance to
definitely all questions you will be
cracking you have cracked marks you'll
be getting number 10th particularly
pondered in the sense thought planned
out
thought you can go are reflected
okay so many answers you can expect for
example here thought are reflected uh
planned okay found a solution etcetera
so pondered is nothing but thought or
reflected or any other relevant answer
okay so that marks the end of or both
discursive as well as case based factual
paragraph so let us go with Section B
grammar now in section B my dear
children we have
uh
verbo Centric grammar okay you are
already aware of it and 12 questions are
given any 10 okay even if we solve 12
questions also no problem at all okay
right so first one B speaks
first one is B that is speaks
because again if you want to see Arena
always Dash the truth
habitual action habitual actions are
normally like my my grandfather reads
the Hindu or reads the Sia SATA reads
the
amruth Bazar patrika isn't it so these
are all habitual actions my dear
children so Reena always speaks the
truth that's the reason
okay next
uh in fact number two select the correct
option to fill in the blank for the
given line bread and butter
bread and butter seem to be different
nouns here but together they stand for a
single unit that's why we would like to
go with a option that is is number two
is so is option given as a
okay number two is is bread and butter
is my favorite breakfast lion order is
what I want to see in my state yes or no
clear next read the conversation between
two friends Ravi and Rina complete the
sentence by reporting only reena's reply
okay so Ravi ask Rina to lend him 100
rupees to which Reena replied that what
Rena replied here very simple Reena
replied that she did not have it right
then but she would arrange it for him
okay if you want me to uh right down
here I can just a moment two answers can
make a possibility here for example look
into this question okay
because
Rina delivered here of course one
dialogue but there is a comma I don't
have it right now
first class then but I will arrange it
for you this can be creatively arrange
in two ways first way you can see here
for example
um yeah question is number three so
number three can enjoy two answers
there has been tradition okay key can
have multiple answers also so third one
if you ask me first it it will be like
this replied that she
didn't
this is the first change we have to do
she didn't
have it right then
eat
right then
but continue again if any present
scenario if you see change it into past
but future but she would arrange it for
him but
she would
arrange
it for him changes we made you can see
here for you you becomes him will
becomes wood doesn't you know I don't
becomes did not okay now becomes then
these are the four changes okay I
Becomes of course she no doubt about it
okay these are some of the things this
is one way second way if you want to
know
uh yeah some children might have written
the other way also around for example C
replied that
she would arrange it for him
in this way she would
arrange
it
for him
as
as she didn't have it right then as she
didn't
have it
right then
we tried to
show connection between her past two
sentences she would arrange it for him
as she didn't have it right now right
then isn't it this can also be second
answer right next
now fourth question select the option
that identifies the error and supplies
the correction for the following line
I can run fast when I was young
now see this sentence when I was young
past tense
so there is a mismatch of I can and I
was can is nowhere attached to this one
we call past indicator was so I could
without seeing also you can guess now
option number it becomes C can has to
become good so c will be what you call
just a moment C becomes here
um yeah question number four
C error is a can and correction will be
good I could run fast when I was young
okay
so it is very useful for us while
writing even descriptive answers as well
okay fourth layer then we'll go with the
fifth answer right then okay fifth
children complete the given narrative by
filling in the blank with the correct
option Hina Dash
from fever since last Sunday so whenever
we use just a minute
uh fifth question whenever we come
across since
are far
as a preposition we must follow
perfect continuous tense are present or
past no doubt about it so automatically
it becomes
if you check the options
suffered is there will suffer supper has
been suffering so obviously has been
suffering becomes the right answer so
has been suffering for the question
number this one
okay fifth question fifth question has
been suffering
perfect
continuous tense
has been suffering next now we can have
another one sixth question yeah option
here becomes D undoubtedly
sixth question fill in the blank by
using the correct word in the bracket
and yes Dash eat all the chocolates kept
in the tray so eight eating eating you
cannot put there since there is no
auxiliary work have it and we cannot say
because anyas stands for singular third
person
okay eat and also not possible there is
no hair has hair so we will go with the
option A A8 so sixth question has an
answer a
eight tier okay right then let's go
ahead now let us because we probably
there is a chance of discussing set
three also since board has released
total three sets so we have to March
past rather come down children report
the dialogue between a mother and a DOT
a daughter by completing the sentence
mother why are you looking so worried
that my exams are approaching in
response to the question of the mother
the daughter replied that her exams were
approaching her
exams
were
approaching
now what changes we made
R becomes were my becomes
her
OK my exams are approaching becomes her
exams were approaching in this way next
we have seventh
the ship Titanic and her fate continues
to Fascinate the imagination of the
people
so in this question my dear children
number eight if you see
her fade is somewhat not acceptable
because her is used for human beings in
that context and Titanic of the famous
sheep you know in the 20th century in
the first uh beginning of 20th century
we can say
there was a great disaster ok so
the Sheep Titanic and her fate her fate
should be its fate so her has to be
changed into its
okay possessive pronoun it becomes its
its fate clear so number eight over now
let's go with number nine
then we'll go with number 10 at a time
okay number yeah
number nine
Ritu and randeeper talking again a
dialogue report
only ritu's question
Ritu says where are you going so Ritu
asked randeep already Ritu ask is there
so we will write down here run the I
mean dash dash dash okay run the what
what did she ask Ben deep where
he was going
where he was going changes we have to
see whether it is properly edited or not
any error Corrections are there let us
have a glance where are you going
present continuous tense U stands for
randeep okay so where he
okay now yes here we have to add VAR
exactly this is very important you know
we get in a Flash that answer is ready
and hurriedly we go so we have to be
careful error correction if any possible
errors are happening so we have to have
a glance at it okay so where are you
going to ask randeep
where
where he was going present continuous
becomes
past continuous and where are we retain
we don't change it okay if you want this
you know yes here here where comes where
he was going that's all okay so we have
to keep on checking checking
after writing something right come down
anyhow you have done it very well I hope
so and number 10th yeah we have to do
that number 10th question
here we go fill in the blank by choosing
the correct option to complete the
slogan
Dash smile and pass it to others so
short smile is little
negative humble smile okay but smiles
are not humble
happy smile Smiles are
inertly they are happy so no problem so
option becomes C always okay see all now
if you read it like this we understand
always smile and pass it to others okay
so let us zero in on this answer okay
then we have 11th question also let us
go ahead 11th question children
ha select the correct option to complete
the narration of the dialogue between
Anil and Sanju
where are you going Anil says sanjiv to
the to the airport May I drop you there
as I am going in that direction
Anil asked Sanju where he was going and
offered to draft him
as he was going in that direction
so as
he was
going
in
that
Direction so it is pretty clear okay on
that from that so once again yes
clear chiller as he was going in that
direction
so past continuous tense because in the
question we have got
present continuous tense as I am going
to so may I drop you has already been
mentioned here after May I drop you has
been
modified into offered offer to draft him
as he was going in that direction as he
was going in that direction full stop
right okay final question that is number
12 let us
understand
12th question it is all about identify
the error in the newspaper headline
attractive packages for different
tourist destination mizoram Kashmir
Kerala and Goa dear Children See mizoram
Kashmir Kerala Goa number of
destinations are there yes or no so we
can call it attractive packages for
different packages vary from place to
place basing upon based upon their
distance okay the more the distance the
package will definitely
ah will be rather expensive okay
the package what you call
magnitude will increase so we can call
it that destinations are given
differently like mizoram Kashmir Kerala
or different state so destinations yes
or no so why can't we zero in our
destinations
okay this is the
and that marks the end of your section B
okay now in section B of course we have
ah creative writing skills that's all
about descriptive you know later writing
100 to 120 words and then we have uh
yeah children be happy I can understand
okay very good uh you have analytical
paragraphs okay so that that doesn't
make any problem at all because those
are scoring areas danger will be there
in form of extracts sometimes discursive
case based and even grammar also but all
together you have come across a come
across a wonderful practice so it's not
an issue but extracts we need to
definitely discuss okay so extracts my
dear children if you have a glance at it
okay first one will go with 60a okay
I'll directly share the answer with you
okay instead of wasting your much time
probably set next set also will be under
discussion okay very soon so sit ah
extracts first set okay just make a note
of them first one you know number one
completely alone
completely alone in the sense
ah just a minute
extracts
dear children six point a
in that first
one two three
four and five okay right so in that
first one completely alone this one
it's about of course from the Diary of
Anna Frank
okay that paragraph famous paragraph
okay next second becomes your D answer
okay then you have spoke about common
things okay day to day things we can say
spoke about
common things
yeah children that is clear and number
fourth we have ah
something okay
number fourth is
something and number five becomes your
to do something unwillingly bring myself
up to something
it's an idiomatic expression okay so
there to do something unwillingly
to do
something
unwillingly
not pleasantly not willingly okay bring
myself bring oneself to do something
that is quite you know we show lots of
reluctance and unpleasantness okay to do
something unwillingly and your option
becomes here B
okay so let's go now let rush towards uh
set B I mean extracts itself in extracts
now I can
it's all about it is taken from yeah Mrs
Hall almost fell down the stairs in
hysterics so here if you see McQ is one
two
one four one four and total three mcqs
and two direct objects uh objective
questions so 60 B let me write down here
sixth B my dear children if we write
like this one two it will be easy for us
to complete and fine
she was in a state of panic first one so
C
she was
in a
state of panic if my voice is audible I
need not even write okay
but those were involved in the charts
for them it is okay she was in a state
of panic first to see second one
spirits
okay second one is the spirit
okay next one
into her in third one
into her in
and fourth one if you see d
and that is for
one and six standard and agitated one
and sixth standard shocked and agitated
and fifth if you see number a again that
becomes your ghosts yes or no g h o s t
s
ok so
in this way we have completed sixth B
also let us go for
6 70 a
here we will just Mark like this
suppose if anybody wants to copy down
they can and if you ask me
7 to B also we have the answers
how to crack them you can check it okay
no need to panic at all okay right
because you had got Choice here so
seventh a
this is tiers option A
yeah the passage was of course from
yeah it's okay no problem
yeah from home
clear clears no problem right how to
tell wild animals so next years then we
have false
then we have beginner D novice what is
meant by novice or tiro beginner
then we have number four weeping and
smiling
you check in your question paper you
will find it because Z3 also probably
will be making a presentation of it
then fifth one see it Rhymes and adds
humor
C eater Rhymes basically how to tell
wild animals and
it also adds
humor use humor we can say
clear
so with that we can stop here and let us
go for seventh B OK very quickly first
one tiger in the zoo
tiger in Zoo
second one quiet
third one pause
velvet
fourth one true just a minute give me
I'll move aside
and
a to catch its prey
two
to catch
its prey
well children this this was all about
extracts okay
first Department was about pros and
supplementary reader then poetry versus
poetry now we will slowly step onto
ah
of course
literature part only 40 50 Words answers
again for both Pros poetry Sr and then
100 to 120 Words answers
okay so based on that some value points
I can discuss here okay now if you might
have definitely attempted if yes you
have everybody has attempted okay
see as long as descriptive paper is
concerned as long as descriptive paper
is concerned by your children
ah
it is very simple that
we follow same tactics same techniques
that which we follow for create your
writing skills I mean later writing and
analytical paragraph writing same
tactics are applicable for writing
literature answers okay maybe the
answers magnitude is also about 100 to
120. whatever the practice we incur
whatever the impact we incur in the
writing of 100 to 12 same we try to
exhibit our present in short answers I
mean firm short answer in the sense
medium size dances like 40 to 50 words
again for textual okay so in that way I
can say that of course following all the
value points okay like introduction main
body and conclusion for all the Learners
even for letter writing also we have
introduction uh we have what you say
main body and again we have this one
[Music]
um
conclusion if you see the later whether
it is editor complaint
inquiry or recommendation later or
placing an order but certain
steps we maintain same like first step
you know we call it senders address
okay then of course a line break line
break with you after sentence address we
have date
then we have reader's address
eternal
senders address date reader's address
then we have subject
then we have salutation
just a moment
again then we have what we call Body
normally body
has three parts passage one passage two
and passage three then we have closed
complementary close like yours truly
your sincerely if the person is known to
us we go for your sincerely and here we
just go for signing off isn't it so one
two three four five six seven eight
these all
eight strips for example one two three
four five six seven eight and each pause
is actually based upon the ratio
whatever you planned one line normally
two line break okay that is what the
sample question paper 16 September and a
week back practice question paper also
in its marking scheme specified it okay
and when it comes to
analytical paragraph okay
and analytical paragraph okay of course
it's a cluster of sentences carrying
common idea throughout the paragraph
Okay so it should carry 100 to 120 words
of course there can also be an
introduction main body and conclusion
without showing any much division
whatever the division we try to
establish that should be through
cohesive words okay I hope you are
catching up with my words okay so
obviously you had done it I hope so and
uh I'll definitely
um
say that you have performed very well
God bless you thank you so much
said to be happy
thank you
so good evening students
we completed set one and set two
now let's continue with set three
section year reading comprehension
we have already discussed in setier set
one so it is the same so we are not
going to discuss that in detail
ah now let's continue with Section B
from
set 3 paper
okay set tree as we have already
completed the reading comprehension of
paper one and the paper two like set one
and set two same questions are given
right
so if we discuss that it's only mere
waste of time let's continue with
Section B of A set 3 paper
fill in the blank by choosing the
correct option
the first one
fill in the blank by choosing the
correct option I appreciate even Dash
help given to me
is the question
even little help given to me even much
help given to me
or the little help given to me few help
given to me
so dear students from the options given
you know all a b b they do not match we
are only left with option C even the
little help
okay even
the little
help that is given to me
next second one
read the conversation between Meera and
her father
complete the sentence by reporting the
reply correctly
Mira what did you buy
father I bought a heater
Meera asked her father what he had
bought the father replied that
okay now we need to give this answer
students
what did you buy it is an interrogative
sentence and that is in simple past
tense
we know that when we have to answer this
interrogative sentence has to be
converted into assertive form and simple
past changes to past perfect tense so
applying those rules let us continue
with the answer
okay that he I bought a heater so he
refers to whom father so it is he I
bought he had
bought
a heater
right so that is the answer that he had
bought a heater of course he is given
already in the question
so you have to continue with had bought
a heater
third one
select the correct option in the blank
for the given line
one dash read the newspaper every day we
need to fill in the blank with an
appropriate model verb
okay now one should read the newspaper
every day one would read the newspaper
every day one can read the newspaper
every day one may read the newspaper
every day now we know that it is a
suggestion
so we need to go with option A
like suggesting someone one should read
the newspaper Every Day recommendation
one should read the newspaper every day
fourth question select the option that
identifies the error and supplies the
correction for the following line
now what is given there
I can't
never forget my childhood friend Bella
I can't never forget my childhood friend
Bella so when we read this we understand
that it is
inappropriate it sounds incorrect
okay now where do we have to identify or
where is the wrong error option A can't
can option b forget forgotten option C
mine mine
option D friend friends now as the
statement of the question says I can't
never forget so can't never not never
it's like two negatives used together
like redundancy that is wrong so can't
will be our word in error so option A is
the correct one
it should not be can't it should be can
I can never forget my childhood friend
Bella so even if you say like I can
never forget that's fine or I can't
forget my childhood friend that may be
fine but can't never is always incorrect
question number four is completed we are
with five
complete the given narrative by filling
in the blank with the correct option
the domestic cat Dash related to the
lion and the tiger
the domestic cat be related to the lion
and the tiger the domestic cat is
related to the lion and the tiger the
domestic cat has been related to the
lion and tiger the domestic cat is being
related to the lion and the tiger now if
you see students this is a general truth
okay so this has to be expressed in
simple present tense alone
now none of our options uh apart from a
match with simple present so option A is
sorry option b
says
is so this is
the only answer we have
simple present tense the domestic cat is
related to the lion and the tiger so
option b is the answer for the fifth one
sixth one fill in the blank by using the
correct form of the word in the brackets
word formation correct form of the word
last week it Dash
in Brackets rain heavily and my house
was flooded flooded with water
now in the instruction of the question
and in the statement of the question we
come across the word last week
last week indicates past
so the verbs past form has to be written
here in the blank last week it rained
and this past form is rained heavily
last week it rained heavily
and my house was flooded with water so
for the sixth one the correct word is
rained
seventh
it is again from reported speech
utilizing the given dialogue report the
dialogue between Rashid and his father
by completing the sentence
father how are you getting on with your
studies
Rashid fine I have got a certificate of
improvement from the school
now see students
the dialog box began
with
the equation like this
father asked Rashid how he was getting
on with his studies
Rashid replied that
okay so connecting word is already used
now we need to say like what did he
reply I have got a certificate of
improvement it is in present perfect
tense so we know that present perfect
tense changes to past perfect tense I
have got a certificate okay Rashid
replied that I have got I here refers to
Rashid so Rashid is he so he have got
changes to had got
we continue with the same he had got a
certificate of improvement from the
school as it is given in the question we
continue with the same but this needs to
be changed like he had got
eighth question
identify the error in the given sentence
and Supply the correction
playing outdoor games have benefits
being indoors
now what is the subject of the sentence
students playing outdoor games
but in this again
like playing is a subject what we play
it's like again object so playing
outdoor games
now we cannot select playing out the
games have
so have is incorrect there so how should
be replaced with have playing outdoor
games has
benefits guava being indoors so have is
the error has is the correction
next question number nine
Raman shared some information with Sema
report CMAs question
can you solve the sum
can you solve the sum okay it is same as
question so our answer begins with the
SEMA
Seema
questioned whom did she question Raman
Seema questioned Raman
can you solve this sum it begins with
can
okay so it's like Sr no type question so
the connecting word would be if
SEMA asked Rahman if can you solve the
sum
it's a question a question should be
written in the form of an assertive
sentence so if can you you refers to
Raman so Raman is a masculine so we need
to go with he if he can solve can
changes to code if he could solve
the sum
So This Is The Answer students
SEMA questions are asked Rahman if he
could solve the sum
extend one
fill in the blank by choosing the
correct option we Dash not really change
a man's mind and heart with money
we cannot really change a man's mind and
heart with money we could not really
change a man's mind and heart with money
we may not really change a man's mind
and heart with money or we might not
really change so out of all these
options option A sounds better because
it is not possible for us we express
inability by using can not cannot so we
cannot really change
a man's mind and heart with money so
option A is the answer for question
number 10. next 11th one
fill in the blank by choosing the
correct option economics Dash difficult
for the students of grade nine
so the word economics is the subject of
this sentence so the subject verb
agreement now economics the word looks
like a plural but it is only a single
subject so we need to take it as a
singular and use the singular verb
economics is difficult economics are
difficult economics has difficult
economics were difficult so we are only
left with option A economics is
difficult for the students of a grade
nine
next question number 12 fill in the
blank by choosing the correct option
if you had worked hard you dash have
passed
conditional clauses
type 3 conditional clauses so the
subordinate clause is in
past perfect tense if you had worked
hard you dash half past you may have
passed you will have passed you would
have passed you might have passed we
know structurally okay in type 3 the
subordinate clause is in past perfect
tense and the main Clause will have like
could have or would have so in the given
options we only have wood there so
option C is the correct answer for 12th
one
yes students so this is very simple I
believe all of you score 10 on 10 isn't
it
how many of you score 10 on 10 in this
uh section B of set 3 paper
okay so the first one the little second
one had bought a heater third should
fourth a is the correct one can't is
error can is the correct one fifth
option b is sixth the verb form range is
the correct one seventh one he had
bought eighth one have is incorrect has
is the correction ninth one okay a
question is given and it should be
reported see my question Raman if he
could solve the sum tenth one
option A can is the answer eleventh one
option A is the correct answer and 12th
one option C Wood is the correct answer
okay so
uh
we need to continue with the remaining
things dear students I am sure this
discussive passage case based passage
and grammar helped you to score full
marks really if you have scoring if you
are scoring full marks on all these
three you know you are very nearer to
score the maximum marks
anyway for further instructions and some
more input on this set three paper I
again invite our amul sir to continue
welcome sir thank you students
the children welcome back to set three
we'll come back to set three uh here the
plus point we can say from Mr ajaru's
discussion also we it was clearly proved
that only grammar section section B is
50 we can see grammar that from that
also a few questions were repeated in
different sets Okay but all together
grammar has less number of repetitions
okay and similarly creative writing
skills also have very almost no
repetitions in set a set B and set C set
one set to set three
factual paragraphs they are grossly
repeated you know through all the three
sets this is one good news for us
actually it is basically 80 20 rule
which were that is what the board
actually follows okay so what where
repetition frequency has been relatively
low was grammar
but again questions were very easy so
you nailed it creative writing skills
and from literature also extracts were
uh almost repeated like stance it was I
can say are very easy questions even
like idiomatic expressions like bringing
myself into something it was a very easy
in our classroom situation itself you
have come across isn't it so next you
know literature related again 40 50 or
100 to 120 words
this this can't be repeated because the
thing is that they are directly taken
from textbook okay let us come to Now
set three that is again section b letter
writing first letter was editors second
was complaint letter okay and for all
all the formal letters we follow all the
eight steps and analytical paragraph we
have we have had table and bar so let us
have a glance now
um
here dear children whenever we go for
formal letter already we have discussed
in our previous class even now also and
I hope you did it you nailed it okay so
those eight steps for example
um yeah just a moment
here we go with
analytical paragraph if you see
we
analyze analysis
why analytical paragraph
is necessary for us already later
writings eight steps we came across
analytical paragraph becomes Paramount
in understanding the things in you know
comp reading comprehension is almost
everywhere even in grammar also even
section c also everywhere reading
comprehension comprehension makes its
presence felt roaring presence is felt
about reading comprehension so whenever
we come across an analytical paragraph
or of course as per board instructions
that has to be written into a single
para but again the first line normally
has this Factor okay which we call
introduction
introduction plays a very crucial role
into analytical paragraph title is not
mandatory whether you write a title or
not so I hope whether you wrote or not
that doesn't make any ah big change in
your scoring scoring will remain the
same definitely will score full marks in
analytical paragraph after you after
induction
the paragraph demands the main body this
we can show I mean without any
transition
like in letters we leave two line break
after introduction introductory para
main body and conclusion here
without leaving any space also because
it is called analytical paragraph is
nothing but a cluster of sentences
analytical paragraph is nothing but a
cluster
of
sentences
so already you did it and the topic was
for table it was women's education
women's education and for bar graph
digital device purchased in saibabad
digital devices purchased in Sai Baba
okay so my decision introduction main
body and conclusion
and that should be in form of a cluster
as per the sample question paper pattern
released on 16 September and even a week
back practice question paper Okay this
thing the division the transition among
these three points introduction main
body and conclusion we show with the
help of you know
analytical paragraphs is nothing but a
cluster of sentences
second parameter it should also show
some cohesion
and also coherence
I mean sequence of actions taking place
for example okay after a b after b c
after a sentence B sentence that must we
have to keep on writing by establishing
connections between the previous
sentence or statement and the upcoming
sentence okay that is possible with the
help of uh cohesive devices for that
devices we normally make use of okay
license devices like furthermore
additionally nowadays thankfully are all
the connections taken from English
grammar like subordinating conjunctions
when okay as
since because as etcetera okay and some
adverbials also you can take like
nonetheless nevertheless however
Etc using comparative degrees also okay
we keep on writing analytical paragraph
okay so this is what I wanted to convey
I wish you once again a wonderful result
waiting for you ahead okay with that I
sign off with me and myself okay
yeah ah just yeah let me invite Mr Ajay
risham here okay
yeah maybe
okay
literature
so dear students one more thing I would
like to tell you
related to this literature
even in uh
set one paper also I think we item I
don't remember exactly you know this
this is given
OK uh six seven b d s two and seven b
read the following extract and answer
the questions that follow
he hears the last voice at night the
patrolling cars and states with His
Brilliant eyes
at the brilliant Stars he starts in his
Vivid stripes
a few steps of his cage
now based on this
extract
we have again five questions now let me
just give these answers to you students
the first one whose is the last voice
heard by the Tiger
so it is already given in the extract
itself
he hears the last voice at night the
petroleum cars so we have option b
the petroleum cuts
next second one
complete the sentence appropriately it
is clear that repetition is the poetic
device used for His Brilliant eyes at
the brilliant stars because
we need to explain how alliteration
explain applies here because
the sound of B is repeated in the
neighboring words
brilliant eyes at the brilliant Stars so
that is the answer repetition of the
sound B at the neighboring words
okay next third one students the main
contrasting ideas in this extract are
contrasting ideas opposing ideas in this
contrast tiger and deer cruelty and
sympathy confinement and freedom master
and slave so our option is
correct option is option C confinement
and
freedom
next fourth one
the use of the word Starks creates an
image of
coverage frustration lethargy
purposefulness so we know from our
understanding of the poem we know that
Starks creates an image of a frustration
option b is the correct
next fifth one students
State whether the following statement is
true or false
the poem uses
staring at the sky to symbolize the
freedom he earns for
what do you think it's true or false
yes it is true the poem uses staring at
the sky to symbolize the freedom he
earns for so it is true
so this is what related to 7B students
in case we missed it please take note of
this so with this I am sure we have
covered all set one two three papers
I also believe that all of you have
given your best and you have presented
the paper correctly
wish you all the very best dear students
for the good result and do prepare well
for the upcoming examinations also see
you again thank you all